[Musique]
en fait on ne fait plus peur on fait
dans le rire maintenant désert qui vous
nomme tous les deux à la tête du serveur
vous rigolez le riz est notre ami il va
falloir embaucher une bonne armée de
monstres marrante s'il vous plaît que
tyler scott terreur attitré quoi terrain
vous voulez dire que vous n'engagiez
plus de terreur adieu les terreurs
bonjour les blagueurs c'est une blague
affecté à la mi
les petits nouveaux et la thaïlande ont
été meilleurs potes à l'université on a
suivi d'un cours en soi même et quelques
courses et même pas parlé excusez moi
c'est quoi exactement la mif c'est quoi
la mif tu as laissé par la monstre
intervention forced him
qu'aucune machine a besoin d'être
entretenues ou l'entretien à toi
on n'en parle plus jamais personne n'a
rien vu bon personne n'ait rien fait je
venais ici à titre provisoire une qui
doit être créé aucun des mister ne
quittera son poste je vais apprendre aux
terreurs à devenir drôle je vois sur
c'était une excellente idée ils viennent
de livrer le casque et le badge de la
jeune recrue bienvenue chez monstres et
compagnie
[Musique]